abbiamo profanato le cucine di tutti i
nostri familiari
abbiamo messo a repentaglio la nostra
incolumità ogni volta che ci siamo
avvicinati ai fornelli o
no ragazzi fate rivoltato esclusa la
caffettiera abbiamo assaggiato senza
paura i piatti che sono stati creati dal
nostro chef premiato con ben tre stalle
michelle è un abominio perché era il
caso noi con una salsetta
[Applauso]
benvenuti a una nuova era di cucina
portata
che sarà sempre la stessa merda
mamma mia c'è una merda
[Musica]
benvenuti ragazzi alla nuova edizione di
cucina buttata
con estate ragazzi decisi del mancate un
sacco era da un pochino che volevamo
tornare la copia dell'immaginare mettere
in piedi tutto questo non è stato
proprio velocissimo tra parentesi che ne
pensate del nuovo set noi siamo molto
contenti fateci sapere questo nei
commenti qual è la vostra impressione a
caldo ma soprattutto dateci un pochino
di conforto di sostegno perché ora come
non mai ne abbiamo bisogno per
quest'anno è veramente un sacco di nuove
idee ma la cosa che ci ha veramente
paralizzato e stato pensare alla prima
ricetta da fare quindi abbiamo fatto un
summit con tutti i grandi esperti di
food nel mondo e abbiamo trovato un
piatto secondo noi perfetto perfetto
perché uno dei piatti più cucinati in
italia è un piatto che ha salvato
milioni e milioni di ragazzi hanno
iniziato a rivedere da soli dall'oggi al
domani ma soprattutto è perfetto secondo
me perché il suo sapore è paragonabile
solamente una respirazione bocca a bocca
con un successo
sto parlando della pasta col tonno
prima di partire con gli ingredienti
però è arrivato il momento di
presentarvi lui il grande assente di
cucina buttata negli ultimi due anni non
abbiamo mai usato con lui forse era già
capito se l'avete capita mente dell'hulk
adesso ora in questo momento 321 l'avete
messo che è perfetto ormai troppo tardi
perché sa tornata nel nostro form di
cucina buttata dopo tanto tanto tanto
tempo e le grembiule
molto peggio
punto
no
[Applauso]
john bomba ingredienti per fare la pasta
col tonno avremo bisogno di pasta tonno
passata dai capelli del vostro naso una
tv da olio extravergine d'oliva
peperoncino e sale machine
partiamo subito ragazzi benvenuti
bentornati anche a voi come state bene
grazie fare prima la pasta con tonno
tendenzialmente non a tutti questi
ingredienti che sia chiaro cioè se
ventura è una pasta bolton col tonno noi
invece la faremo un pochino più
elaborata come funziona ragazzi
istruzione che le è proprio non è il mio
mondo abbiamo pensato di venerdì con
dalle cuoche come sei simpatico da
quanti mesi della prepari bassa che va
dal lavoro che cosa è una padella di
merda dovevo comprare nuovi pannelli e
ragazze gianmarco era felicissimo ci
avremmo una padella sì certo e mandato
il cofano da macchina una volta stavo
con una mia amica che dovuto a casa mia
mi fa ho fame ma che ti faccio la pasta
con un po di tonno trs volturno che
merda ho fatto questa variante da allora
le ha detto ti prego fammi sempre la
pasta corta
e facciamo enrico dei con un atto sito
per me
tagliamo le cipolle che vuoi dire nella
pasta col tonno finale vede guglielmo
sai come si chiama la cipolla dopo viene
tagliata c povera
una cipolla che che assomiglia si piglia
se avete altri iscrivetevi qua sotto la
cipolla un po smaliziata
cc volta una cipolla proteica cipolla
e la cipolla
affronteremo 6 induzione davvero così
grave no no no non ho visto l'acqua
[Musica]
avete un minuscolo ma non ho visto
l'acqua campanella per guardare sotto
che l'assessore al collasso che me ne
vado
il metano la somma come telecamera con
la cosa da eric aspirante valutazione
che non sono
ma io
batteria
grigino
[Musica]
ma non è nulla si è mosso
e normale
ragazzi e la pasta col tonno non
possiamo stare così che possiamo fare
una cosa dove io parlo con sottomento
ragazzi ci vediamo 5 secondi e torniamo
dopo il tetto di comprare una padella
scrivete quello che volete nei commenti
metteteci polisi
metteteci
siamo tornati ecco qui la padella
troviamo certo punto ragazzi giro d'olio
e mi voglio fidare vediamo di civiltà un
mestolo serve quello delizia la pietra
non è quel grazie sono ancora
impolverati antonio e cipolla guarda la
cipolla che stappa lo chef e dire che
qui ci siamo a questo punto passatina di
film
non avevamo la padella secondo te
abbiamo un paraschizzi tra queste che
permette cucina perché sa culi cioè date
thu girate così fine un po di sale
[Musica]
ma è molto salato
my two considera sta riparlando e mentre
parla di già stati salando d'amore nel
sugo
cappelli per un po disabilità non fanno
bene ma sento da un po di anni
peperoncino e poi intorno col tonno
aggiungiamo il tonno ragazzi prendiamo
un buon filetto di tonno cioè va bene
anche con l'impegno più scampo ma se
volete trattarli bene e poi signori io
credo di più scadente calcolati marina
ha creato secondo me un logo pazzesco
cucina ha buttato oppure cresci bene
ai ragazzi che avete dato un caso che a
tutti e ovunque
rivaleggiare no io voglio
io c'ho questo caso che
la magistratura
no perché non mangiare la pasta cruda ma
dove hai fatto nella vita senti tu mangi
gli impasti nella pizza ragazzi
veramente sede di gente che mangia pasta
cruda c'e qualcuno e mangia pasta cruda
fatemi sapere un altro
problema
ora che ci mettono anche gli spaghetti
malissimo ma tu non sei più bravo voglio
io mossi col vetro
non voglio assaggiare mai
cosa non faresti pur di apparire davanti
alle telecamere
come si muove però uno sbaglio in questa
cucina ragazzi inizia malissimo questa
nuova edizione scusate ce l'abbiamo il
il caso per scolare sì che ce l'abbia
punto s'è mangiato la pasta la pasta
cruda ma ve l'ho detto che vuole mai
fuori stiamo lavorando qui ti sto
pagando il college mai non ci abbiamo il
coso per mescolare quella specie di
mestolo particolare fatto che duke into
rete però propiziato il tempo di
attrezzarci minimo mai aveva potevamo
prevedere una padella cosa fai pazzo
leader fascista insegnarmi
allora se non gli spareggi primo giorno
non sbagli mai spa dell'eroe enrico un
po di acqua di cottura opera opera opera
opera opera opera
per la marina che terrorizzata ma questa
è una pasta che mi entusiasma ultimo
giro d'olio a crudo
a questo punto per quanto mi riguarda
possiamo passare all'assaggio ma prima
di farlo invito a iscrivervi al suo
canale perché ci siamo fatti struscio di
culo chance o no ciò non ultima la
cerchi un pollice in su perché insomma
siamo fatti subito regula passiamo alla
saggio di questa pasta con tonno urne
non abbiamo fatto 200.000 volte questo
però non si sono dette lovecchio
[Musica]
che buoni
qualcuno vuole associare ragazzi quanto
sono a tema pazzesco quanto sono a tema
pazienza associati ragazzi enrico
adibire ad un
pool di insalata non è salata buona
ma buono
dire che il sale è perfetto perfetto
però dovete farla sarà la così comunque
ci siamo tolti la prima ricetta un'ansia
pazzesca quindi l'abbiamo buttata lì non
mi devo dirlo ci vediamo la prossima
domenica con una puntata di cucina
mutata ciao
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]